on the front line with the defense
secretary are you new lead commissioner
here is that right
but this is no ordinary battlefield
[Music]
right now middlesbrough has the highest
covert case rate in the country
this hospital's unique relationship with
forces medics is helping turn the tide
but a year into this crisis even with
military support
everyone is shattered and how you all
and
sort of tiredness exhaust i mean it has
been full-on for all of you
in a way that it's been very full on
really and our nhs teams have been
fantastic
but we are becoming exhausted from the
team to becoming exhausted
the forces have been working hand in
hand with the nhs here for years but
during kovid their skills have made
all the difference they've helped us
with our vaccination center
they've helped us at all levels even in
our command and control structure we've
learned from them
on how to run um you know in this
pandemic
it's been just a brilliant brilliant
relationship
and we couldn't have done it without
them but even when case rates fall here
and patients are discharged
the non-covered wave begins people have
been waiting for treatment
there will be no break what's happening
here mirrors the rest of the country
in some areas like a e they're starting
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel but the closer you get to the
heart of this hospital
the further away normal feels michelle
is in charge of intensive care
we're still experiencing experiencing
the same pressures that we had
in the first wave back in april last
year we've seen
three definite peaks and we're still at
the peak in the northeast of england
the vaccine rollout
hasn't had an impact on critical care
admissions yet it mustn't feel like
you're about to get a break
so at the moment we're still seeing new
patients with kovid admitted and we know
that they're going to be with us for a
number of weeks
and we know that there's a big backlog
of patients who are waiting for care and
we're aiming to deliver as much care as
we possibly can to everybody who needs
it
and the battle against kovid will carry
on too but ministers know burnt out nhs
staff can't carry on like this forever
now the defense secretary is promising
extra help
i know people are going to be exhausted
in this hospital and that means we have
to care for them
and give them respite so that when
hopefully things get back to normal
they're not running on empty
um and so you know we'll be looking in
defense about how we can
help the nhs deliver that how our
defense can just find the right people
to relieve some people to give them that
break
and you know i think that'll make all
the difference
talk in westminster is about lifting
lockdown and can we book a holiday
you know is that the right message to be
giving to people who are still
struggling
we all feel it you know we are all have
been in a 12 months plus of
some form a lot down and personally we
all feel it
and you know it's like a devil and an
angel on our shoulder and i wouldn't
pretend it's any different
so but the key thing is to remember it
is about making sure the flow into
hospitals are managed
because if that falls over that's when
we get into real problems on monday
boris johnson will set out his plan for
ending lockdown
and like all of us he's wrestling with
the choice between offering hope for the
future
and protecting the most vulnerable after
such a difficult year
the staff here hope he gets it right
kate mccann sky
news middlesbrough